now it's over at Sony Pictures along and
like this is just I think this video
came out before this Sony Pictures
announcement happened I think Jason was
still attached to star in it well I like
Jason Momoa and generally but in terms
of I've read it's one of the few graphic
novels I can say I actually read I read
the graphic novel that they're saying
this reboot is supposed to be even more
faithful to and I feel like casting
massively tall not rock I was loved and
playing rock I was waiting lifting all
the time diet gains are yeah
oh my god is that the reject nation oh
yes it is
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrys a
moccasin ah kasam Bailey hey I'm saying
hey ah kasam was in a sketch the first
time I met up with him now he's actually
doing the thing you guys probably wanted
him to do with us creative don't worry
what else is gonna get reactions yeah
we're gonna watch from one of my
favorite YouTube channels of all time
what culture these British dudes are
hilarious and have some great list
videos yeah it's gonna check out their
videos I love their wrestling videos
actually eight upcoming movie that's
true they do that - oh yes and eight of
kamma movie reboots that are doomed to
fail oh man we all love reboots here one
they're all great I haven't seen a bad
one yet now let's check this out we can
do a picture in the day shout out after
the reaction for nuke 2x - x - x double
use all right here we go
ding-ding what we're not doing more than
casting doubt and Joe had over upcoming
video game filming is being proved wrong
so take this as a clear notification the
titles on this list worry me a great
deal in fact but I want them to prove me
wrong I want to have humble place
because being wrong as a chunk to learn
how to be bright and listen up kids I
guess not that was John wrong with this
in my uncle's car there's a upcoming
movie reboots that are doomed to fail
yeah Flatliners film is that no one
really seems to know what the film is
going to be about originally it was
touted as a remake and then later as a
reboot and it's sort of being marketed
as a sequel now of source it's very
confusing the story of the original
focused on what lies in the afterlife
with a group of friends purposefully
flatlining and resuscitating themselves
in order to experience the things that
lie beyond and do there before the
film's release is anyone's guess but if
not expect this film to start beginning
this seems to the scales producer mark
Gordon who has confirmed that his 9-year
tell will be an adaptation of book for
the Silver Chair a bad book by any
stretch but then again surely this is
going to alienate chase bank of the Wow
and it makes sense to start with book
The Magician's Nephew which is actually
never been put to film seeing is the
other Narnia films didn't exactly set
the world on fire it's harder imagine
that picking up a story halfway
throughout to do any better
number six original movie The Crow
reboot simply will not die respite an
eternity and development at our studio
closures and a multitude of other
setbacks
executive producer at Xavier Gutierrez
permed as recently as this year that the
ill-advised project still remains on the
carts the number of actors have been
linked to the role of bribing but says
any crew fan really want this to come to
those heinous pro sequels turn number
five the Naked Gun Wow do I think he's
the type of guy that I'd like to go and
have a punt of the good stuff with and
then go suit shopping with while
chatting about the finer qualities of
Adam Blum piays mums underwear
collection what I'm trying to say is
that he's a man with range yet I don't
want to see him as Frank Drebin why
who's why because Naked Gun had a factor
that really cannot be replicated think
how many other films
oh no the joke factory that actually
worked
Jerry Hugh is the answer and when you
realize this is being penned behind a
mind to shut out Night at the Museum oh
really this reboot of this teen slasher
piece of crap has made it better now
interestingly enough the film is being
held by that's he who made hush this is
a franchise that really did die off
quite definitively so it's hard to see
what they can do to bring it back number
three the fly biggie mate you're not
gonna top Cronenberg when it comes to
body that is going to be able to achieve
the original flight has been remade
reimagined and repackaged to perfection
so deconstructing it for a second time
is that best unnecessary and at worst
sacrilege of the highest order
no to Jumanji to the con I'm too excited
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
the rock why dwayne johnson said that
this is a continuation of the original
raises so many like if this is so then
that means the board game that was in
the first one was digitized and turned
into a video game which is so very
stupid the actual comedy of this film
looks like it could actually work it
could but why attach this to Jumanji it
would have worked as its own film yeah
yeah very very sounds of it this is
something we're very worried about
because Jumanji is an extremely special
film for many of us on the office by
number one police academy I like
campaign I like Palmas landscape I loved
police academy yet what really worries
me about this reboot of silly piggies is
this just being described as grounded
weiss now instantly makes it seem that
all of the silliness is just gonna be
curbed and the over-the-top nature of
the police officers potentially dark
back and where does that leave us just
another comedy with the police be sure
after the jokes we've seen that so many
times over so where's the fun and that's
on this one the other more news now
schools like this every goddamn day as
always are being jewels you be awesome
yeah subscribe to what culture guys do
it missus okay and before we go into our
discussion on this walk culture video I
want to give a shout out to nuke 2x
thanks for letting me here hey no that's
honoring Scotland what he wanted us to
give a shout out to his stepdads YouTube
channel it's like a vlog Channel ooh I
don't know how to say what it's called
so here is a screenshot I can't even
read that yeah
it's a really cool vlog channel I saw
some videos didn't understand any of it
cuz it's all in Russian but go check it
out if you're Russian if you're one of
our Russian subs yeah one of them
Russian subscribers yeah alright say the
first one I talked about Flatliners yeah
that's that's a good point because that
came out of like i think ninety or
ninety something those nine days is
nineties and I'm a 90s Johnson nice
child and we know plenty of nineties
children and people before and so a lot
of people haven't even seen Flatliners
right I've many of people I'm having my
eyeliner reasonably popular film
honestly if you is just a straight-up
reboot remake I might have been a little
more on board for that but the fact that
they are donning it as a sequel and
keeper supposed to being in I'm like you
really relying on nostalgia here for
Flatliners which a lot of people still
seem like they have it looks visually
cool the movie like it and I like Ellen
Page but in terms of like hoping to be
this box-office success
I I don't see it being this is grand
think no one even seems excited about
that anyone know about it till today
yeah seems like people either don't know
or just aren't really thinking about it
and like I get the vibe I get off
Flatliners is especially because they've
changed what the impression is supposed
to be and then never it communicates a
good vibe to me I almost figured figure
like this is gonna come out and maybe
make a little money and kind of slip out
of theater yeah like won't be terrible
won't be great and it'll just kind of go
Chronicles of Narnia you seem excited
about this a kissing only because I've
actually never seen the originals or any
of them so it's it's an interesting
concept you read all 27 books
not at all and I didn't even know it was
based on a book until late in the game
really yep couldn't even get that vibe
Lonely Island taught me about The
Chronicles of Narnia what what cold
that is still a terrific song they make
a great point here though like the the
first movie was the third book I think
second second Rosie why yeah number one
they did that the first time they
adapted it to everybody starts at the
Lion the Witch and the Wardrobe got
seven stories to draw from a nowadays
suspect like before I got it I was like
okay you want to cherry pick one book
we're not franchise minded fine but you
know nowadays even when they started the
new franchise you know with Tilda
Swinton and all that why don't you just
start at the top and go through all
seven and and I feel like what they're
trying to do is make these later and
like they're adapting these ones that
are later books make those huge and then
do prequels we love prequels very fun
now why things become what they became
well yeah they're ripoffs about you know
what is putting is to it and to the I
guess the opposite side of the coin is
like not all the books are about the
same characters but some of them are ya
know I don't yeah I don't know how
they're going to the Silver Chair seems
like an odd idea if we're gonna reboot
Narnia again why go even deeper have you
not seen them nope things that kind of
just passed the time while I was
transferring over yeah I'm more of a
game of Thrones kind of guy never know
your boy Khal Drogo and the crow they're
just reacting to a piece of news on this
so really look assam what are your
thoughts on the crow reboot I'm kind of
for it but at the same time as they kind
of mentioned with Jumanji there's kind
of a special place it like the crow has
a special place in the 90s that will
always be there randomly everything like
you know it's kind of like I rather do
not mess with it at all
I rather them just do something else
sounds like there's so many problems
with this movie to begin with just say
let it just let it die yeah at this
point I feel like they're just trying to
make it to me yeah expecting this so was
this fun when you do it behind the
I was a little bit intrigued when Tom I
believe he was kind of on board I'm like
maybe you could make it work but no it
seems like you're saying they're just
making it to bacon I am the only person
who thinks this so take this with a
grain of salt like I don't think the
crow is impossible to remake I don't
think you can just make it to make it
you know like it seems like they want to
the only time I heard of a crow reboot
and then went yeah was when Rob Zombie
wanted to do it I was like yeah rock and
roll yeah and then like where you're
coming from okay like I get it like if
you're just gonna like find a director
and kind of smash them on it yes I could
theorize all day about what a Rob Zombie
one would be like because you notice how
to capture angry personalities very well
but the crow Eric Draven very hurt guy
from love yes yeah so you combine that's
like seeing that element of love being
hurt and anger combined for the revenge
factor that would have been cool I don't
really know what these guys would really
provide but hey we'll get it one of
these days it's been like 18 years in
the making the Naked Gun is is kind of
how Britain really feels about Point
Break it's like if Leslie Nielsen
there's an in it why do it I mean yeah
like you can't no one can
it's like when they it's not a good plot
we don't love that movie for what Steve
Martin in the first Pink Panther remake
was all right but then the second one
was god-awful and I just kind of feel
like doing naked guy could fall under
that same type of category yeah but do
you think there's anybody with the
nowadays a comedian with that Leslie
Nielsen sort of a pill that could have a
script similar not the same but similar
and people would be into it Dane Cook
okay Steve Carell got close yeah yeah
yeah okay you know I agree yeah cuz if
I'm thinking of this I'm like what like
Ed Helms is for like freaking out over
[ __ ] yeah freaks out a room yeah I've
gotta share this their opinion with
which is sort of I like Ed Helms I'm
usually excited to see him in a comedy
but I can't see him as this as the Naked
Gun I'd say wait and see like I wouldn't
mind them making it it's not gonna cost
them much but they'll just wait and see
with that little cause they can get okay
to be in India
it's the flyer third time's the charm
baby we're all flowery mate they might
get it right this time
that's how I feel maybe the third one
will be so great it'll be like the
greatness of you combined I feel like in
terms of tone and story you could do
another fly make it modern sure
necessary definitely not necessary
practical effects seems like impossible
the top but if they can honor it would
do impractical and body horror we got it
we might get like a great even more
serious type of throw because the food I
think the moment Jeff called was like
little candy exactly gross right scary
but there are times we were like a
Cornish it's still amazing yeah I know
what you did last summer I'm gonna probe
that be remain original is like amazing
we're gonna remake scream I'd be like no
to scream but okay I know what you did
last summer
yeah I know what you did last summer got
overshadowed by scream like scream is so
so specific in tone and style and
characters I see like you were
bellissima remember some scream
characters beyond Ghostface I know they
have a good TV show going right now but
I know what you did last summer I'm like
I remember any carrot I know the actors
I don't know that characters they write
the 13th to like screams Halloween where
it's like okay you know it's not quite
as groundbreaking but you know it's a
bunch of popular teenagers we like in a
similar slasher scenarios yeah and they
have the added benefit of like you have
the fisherman guy goes and that's
something that but you can make it
really I really can you do like a
defined style with a reboot and nobody
really seems to love that movie for
being great yeah what's your problem
moccasins oh I'm just weird enter weed
seed that I just didn't really get the
whole hook I was like alright it is what
do you mean you just don't really care
for I know you did love right we can be
on board with the reboot because though
original is not that great okay yeah
about that Jumanji
like what culture said it would have
been great if they just made it a
different movie why I music why make why
use the name because everybody's gonna
be comparing it to the original and like
we already stated some of these reboots
have a special nostalgic feeling but
it's not because of the story by God no
no no it's the actor that was in it yes
Nilson Robin Williams I like the rock I
like what the rock does would have been
better by a different name and again if
it's gonna be a reboot or if it's a
continuation then why the hell is it a
videogame and not the original board
yeah I would have enjoyed it a lot more
if it was these punk ass kids that stop
playing video games for a second found
the board game in an addict and let's
just play around then they go but the
whole video game concept you lose the
feeling of it the plots kind of
insulting to what you might yeah yeah
only because it's called you Marty if
you had just changed the title to
something well it's like I would have
been okay with a movie that's inspired
by a Jumanji like a movie that would
have been totally acceptable what to
college you mangy like you're not
understanding the rules of the game of
Jumanji in general Robin Williams is in
it it just seems like typical marketing
updates what to do with a Jumanji si
fool so they don't lose the rights to
know some some [ __ ] it's conflicting
because I like a lot of the comedian's
trigger yeah I the thing is I don't
think this movie is doomed to fail
because I think I'll make a lot of money
I think the cast is great I'm excited to
go watch that yes I'll gather I think
the kids are like we're excited because
like everybody has a soft spot for
Jumanji it seems yeah I actually don't
think as heart like I think that the
hook of Jumanji is interesting like the
game itself
I think there's enough there that way
you don't need the original cast if you
don't have them I get that this doesn't
look like yeah this is like spiritually
OnPoint I'm like how did their point
exactly like how did this buried
apparently one off board game become a
digital and also like the motif of
Jumanji is watching them play through
and the fact that they have to convert
yeah very good point I get that they're
in a video game but it looks like
they're just gonna go on an adventure
come back out of the yeah like where is
the keep playing elements and it might
be there what a good point and it seems
like it seems like it's a one joke thing
of the fact they go in there oh I'm the
rock I'm Jack I'm Kevin Hart there's a
specialty if they went in there and they
were those people if you wanted to get
the rock and Kevin Hart to Sarna Jumanji
yes come on with a more clever way to
get like people who are then who go into
the game yeah and said let's get kids
and they transform into this for this
one funny scene were like look who I am
you know I would have had them be like a
bunch of old friends getting together
over a weekend yeah honestly been fine
the last one police academy I don't know
if I get something I'm on the whole
grounded thing to be honest I don't like
the idea of it being grounded at the
same time though if it's they're saying
kyun peels involved in it if they're
involved in it I think they might be
taking the word grounded a little too
literally I just don't think it would be
a yeah you can't ground it but well you
can have grounded comedy different style
yeah cuz they have outlandish sketches
on the key and peele show but they're
not like to the police academy level all
that certainty so I feel like they might
just be dying back a little bit have a
little bit more humor in the dialogue
you as opposed to like crazy slapstick
so that's what I tape roll it's
interesting you're mentioning a crazy
slapstick style but that was also like
what made the appeal of the Naked Gun as
well yeah so it seems like that's gonna
be the big challenges how do you bring
that humor from the Naked Gun or police
academy from back in the day to where we
are now where do those fit now right
that's alright it doesn't make as much
sense anymore it's like the heyday of
the broad farcical parody movie is not
now and not to say that they don't good
ones don't still happen but you know it
always seems like a weird and that
curtain ism when they pop up now so I'm
like you want to remake police academy
this isn't the kind of like free
burgundy shelter are struggling to keep
the game alive in they're doing a
terrible job and nobody seems to be kind
of mourning the death of it alright guys
well thanks for tuning in you can check
out what cultures videos on their
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification
Kayson bell - on Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram patreon.com slash original
rejects become a pitch on eject today
more importantly check haka songs
channeling yet you might have already
heard of him I feel like a lot of people
who've heard of me have heard of him we
kind of just go hand in hand
yeah either way there are no people who
have only heard of me and neither
[Laughter]